[Applaudissements]
c'était pendant l'horreur d'une profonde
nuit je rentrais de gala avec mes
musiciens quand une grosse bête apparu
sous la pluie faisant de l'autostock
comme un vulcire humain je lui ai dit
monter il m'a répondu je suis le loup
garou et toi qui donc es-tu je
suis chanteur
comique je
fais dans la
musique je chante pour les bambinos des
petits refra rigolo mais le louparou m'a
dit tu as rien compris tu es plus dans
le cours dans le long Deen n'importe où
les gens se toent pour le
bougalou si vous me prêtez votre
instrument je vais vous jouer un truc
fument c'est plus qu'un tube c'est un
monument les oiseaux s'arrêtent
gazouiller
les ruissaux s'arrêtent de
gargouiller les martiens quittent leur
soucoupe et les pépés mangent leur soupe
quand le louarou joue le
Bou j'ai deviné en lui une pête de scène
alors je l'ai pris en vedette américaine
et je l'ai présenté à luxe au Carpentier
à Dan Dr fin au monde entier bientôt il
fit rager ses petits camarades en
grimpant comme un fou en haut des parade
et la grosse B
fa devenu
[Musique]
vê les petits enfants tous les soirs
attendent à présent dans le noir devant
la télé le loup qui chante des
contractés dans le langue beaucou dansor
n'importe où les G ce toque pour le
loupgarou je suis resté simple et très
sympa ça fait plaisir à mon papa qui
voulait pas que je fasse ce métier là
les oiseaux s'arrêtent de
[Musique]
gazouiller les ruissaux s'arrêtent de
gargouiller les martiens quittent leur
soucoupe et les pévé mange leur soupe
quand le loup garou joue le boui boui
Bou
Lou
Lou je suis là je suis
là que fais-tu que
fais-tu Gal
Galot m'entends-tu m'entends-tu
oui mon gars oui mon
garsououou
galoufou le
boualou louou ça me rend fou ça me rend
fou le Bou Galou du loupgarou
complètement
[Musique]
fou